So, this was one way that we could find the inverse function. First we switched
the values of x and y, and then we solve for y and replace that with f inverse
of x. Now there is a quicker way to find the inverse of a linear function. I
could jet list out what I did to x. First I multiplied x by 2, and then I took
that result and I added three. So, to undo these operations I would want to
start with the results and do the inverse of this step. So, I start with the
result, which is x, and I'm going to subtract 3 first. Then I'll take that
result and divide it by 2. Notice that to find the inverse function, we first
undo the last step that we performed for f of x. Then we work backwards and
undo each of the steps before. We can see this for an input like x equals 1.
We'll multiply the input by 2, which equals 2, and then we'll add 3 to that
result, which equals positive 5. So, if this is a true inverse function. If I
put in positive 5, I should get out the original input which was 1. So notice,
we'll take 5, use that for the input of our inverse function. And first, we'll
subtract 3, which equals 2. Next, we'll divide that result by 2, so 2 divided
by 2, equals 1. So, notice how our inverse function undoes the operations that
was performed on 1. Our original function with an input at 1 gave us an output
of 5. And then our inverse function with an input of 5 gave us our original
input which was 1.